[موسيقى]
كان إرنست همنغواي من أوائل الشخصيات الأسطورية التي يستخدمونها في
الواقع كما تعلمون أقلامنا ،
وكان القلم في حد ذاته
عنصرًا فاخرًا بالفعل لأنه لم يكن بمقدور الكثير من
الأشخاص الكتابة في الوقت الذي كنا فيه من
بين أول من ابتكر
أدوات الكتابة.  إصدار محدود
لهواة
الجمع ولتطوير الأعمال المصممة حسب الطلب
في أدوات الكتابة بالطريقة التي
نصنع بها الأقلام تغيرت بشكل كبير
في السنوات القليلة الماضية بسبب بالطبع
تغيرت التقنيات هناك
تقنيات جديدة ولكن يجب أن أقول أن
طريقة الأقلام  تم صنعها بالفعل كما هي
، لذا فأنت بحاجة إلى
الحرفيين ذوي المهارات التي يجب أن
يخضعوا لمستوى مكثف من التدريب
خاصة أولئك الذين يعملون في
قسم معين مثل النقش اليدوي
وترصيع الأحجار لجزء المجوهرات
الذي استخدمناه أيضًا أصدقاء الخشب القدامى
من أقلامنا الدوارة استخدمنا
خشبًا يبلغ عمره أربعة آلاف واثني عشر عامًا
[موسيقى]
أنتج Montegrappa
أغلى قلم على الإطلاق  صنع في
العالم وتم بيعه في الصين لمزاد خيري
مقابل 8.5 مليون دولار كان هذا
في عام 2010 وبالطبع كان
مرصعًا بالكامل بالماس والأفلام
ملكة إنجلترا البابا الأمير تشارلز
أو ملك إسبانيا أو ملكة
تايلاند  الملك يقول للأردن أو
نجله ونحن خدمات فيدل كاسترو وحدنا
هو في الواقع أحد المساهمين في
الأعمال متعددة الأطراف
[موسيقى].